now trump is gone
dave chappelle hosted saturday night
live's post
election show for the first time since
2016
when he took the stage following trump's
win
this time around the comedian wore a
dark suit
and smoked a cigarette while he
delivered a controversial politically
charged monologue
and in true chappelle fashion he didn't
hold
anything back call the coronavirus
the kong flute
i said you racist hilarious son of a
supposed to say that not you it's wrong
when you say it
there were moments of seriousness and
savagery
as he reflected on the historic nature
of the election
and donald trump's handling of the
pandemic
you know what he did you know what trump
did after all that stuff
went out and got the corona virus wasn't
that something
you know when he got coronavirus they
said everything about on the news but
you know what they didn't say
that it was hilarious chappelle called
trump out for getting
top-end medical care when he was
diagnosed with profit 19.
but then he turned around and told
everyday people
not to be afraid of the virus cold stuff
man
some cold stuff that would be like me
going to a homeless shelter
with a bag full of hamburgers and say
these is mines
and then just start eating in front of
homes
don't let hunger dictate your life
as the 47 year old near towards the end
of his set
he shared a message to those celebrating
the election results
a reminder to be humble winners remember
when i was here four years ago
remember how bad that felt remember that
half the country right now
still feels that way please remember
that
remember that for the first time in the
history of america
the life expectancy of white people is
dropping
because of heroin because of suicide
all these white people out there that
feel that anguish that pain
they're mad because they think nobody
cares and maybe they don't
let me tell you something i know how
that feels chappelle
also had a message for those struggling
with hate in their hearts
you gotta find a way to live your life
you gotta find way
to forgive each other you gotta find a
way to find
joy in your existence in spite of that
feeling
chappelle also appeared on snl last
season
when he made a cameo during his idol
eddie murphy's
grand return to studio 8h
that was a special moment for the
comedian who has always been vocal
about how murphy influenced his career
here's what he told et
in 2015. if i were lebron james
he'd be the michael jordan poster on my
wall like it kind of was something that
i'd never seen before even though
richard pryor was the first incarnation
of it
eddie was probably amongst the best and
i don't know if that will ever happen
again what he was
you